150 years ago Social Democrats tamed the
first Industrial Revolution by putting
people first we have built a unique
society in Europe with free education
for all because everyone deserves a good
start into life with decent wages and
working standards limiting work to five
days a week and eight hours a day
because life is about much more than
just work
with universal health care and a social
safety net because everyone needs a
helping hand once in a while and a
pension because everyone deserves a
happy retirement at the end of their
working lives we have the freedom to
speak our mind and the right to vote
unlike other parts of the world there is
no child labour no torture no death
penalty however our unique European way
of life is under pressure the digital
revolution automation globalization and
climate change are turning societies and
economies upside down putting our
hard-won rights into question as Social
Democrats we can do it again we can make
this upheaval work for and not against
us by putting people first to protect
and strengthen our unique European Way
of life we are fighting for a better
tomorrow for you and your children